>> TODAY, WE ARE ANNOUNCING THAT
TEXAS WILL BUILD A BORDER WALL
IN OUR STATE TO HELP SECURE OUR
BORDER.
MAKE NO MISTAKE THE BORDER
CRISIS THAT WE’RE DEALING WITH
RIGHT NOW IS A DIRECT RESULT OF
THE OPEN BORDER POLICIES THAT
HAVE BEEN PUT IN PLACE BY THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HOMES ARE
BEING INVADED.
NEIGHBORHOODS ARE DANGEROUS AND
PEOPLE ARE BEING THREATENED ON A
DAILY BASIS.
WE BELIEVE IN THE RULE OF LAW
AND LAW AND ORDER IN THIS STATE
AND BY GOD WE ARE GOING TO STEP
UP AND DELIVER THAT RULE OF LAW
AND LAW AND ORDER IN THE STATE
OF TEXAS.
PETE: AN IMPASSIONED GOVERNOR
GREG ABBOTT TAKING THE CRISIS AT
THE BORDER INTO HIS OWN HANDS TO
MAKE MILLIONS TO BUILD THE
BORDER WALL AND PROTECT HIS
STATE.
WILL: THIS COMES AS THE GOVERNOR
ALSO ANNOUNCES IS HE EMPTYING
OUT A STATE PRISON TO HOUSE
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS WITH LOW
LEVEL OFFENSES.
RACHEL: JOINING US WITH MORE
TEXAS CONGRESSMAN LANCE GOODEN.
>> GOOD MORNING.
RACHEL: WELCOME, CONGRESSMAN.
>> THANK YOU.
RACHEL: TEXAS IS STEPPING UP.
TEXAS IS SAYING WE ARE NOT GOING
TO TAKE THIS.
IF THE GOVERNMENT IS NOT GOING
TO DO IT WE ARE GOING TO DO IT
OURSELVES.
CAN TEXAS DO IT?
>> TEXAS CAN DO IT.
WE DID THIS IN THE YEARS OF THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION.
NOT BUILD A WALL BUT ENFORCE
IMMIGRATION LAW.
WE HAD A REALLY GREAT FOUR YEARS
OF PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP
ACTUALLY DOING WHAT THE
PRESIDENT SHOULD BE DOING AND
THAT IS PROTECTING AND DEFENDING
OUR NATION, INCLUDING AT THE
BORDER.
AND IT’S AMAZING WHAT CAN HAPPEN
IN SIX MONTHS.
SINCIAN, THE BORDER HAS
BASICALLY BEEN OPEN.
OUR OWN VICE PRESIDENT, WHO IS
IN CHARGE OF THIS CRISIS
ACCORDING TO THE PRESIDENT,
HASN’T EVEN BEEN TO THE BORDER.
WE HAVE A SEVERE CRISIS ON THE
TEXAS BORDER.
AND ALL THE WAY TO CALIFORNIA
AND OUR GOVERNOR IS STEPPING UP
AND SAYING WE NEED TO DO
SOMETHING.
WE NEED TO BUILD A WALL.
AND NOT ONLY ARE PEOPLE
SUPPORTIVE OF THAT IN TEXAS, BUT
THERE IS ENOUGH LAND FROM
VOLUNTEERS TO EVEN BUILD MOST OF
THIS LAW BETWEEN STATE LAND AND
LANDOWNERS GIVING UP THEIR LAND
TO THIS BORDER WALL EARTH.
THERE IS AN OUTPOURING OF
SUPPORT ALONG OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER AND I THINK IT’S GREAT
AND I’M PROUD OF OUR GOVERNOR
FOR DOING IT.
PETE: LOVE TO SEE IT THEY ARE
NOT LETTING PEOPLE OUT OF THE
STATE PRISON.
THEY ARE MOVING IT ELSEWHERE SO
THEY CAN ALLOCATE THIS PRISON
FOR ILLEGALS WHO HAVE ALREADY
BROKEN THE LAW BY COMING HERE
ILLEGALLY BUT ALSO HAVE
COMMITTED OTHER CRIMES.
WHAT’S THAT CHANGE?
>> IT’S A CHANGE IN THE SENSE
THAT WE EVEN HAVE TO DO THIS.
WE HAVE BEEN OVERRUN BY
CROSSINGS OF PEOPLE THAT WE
CANNED CONTAIN.
WE HAVE CHILDREN.
I HAVE ASKED THIS ADMINISTRATION
WHAT THEY ARE DOING WITH
CHILDREN.
HOW ARE WE MAKING SURE THAT
THESE CHILDREN NOT BEING
TRAFFICKED?
ARE THEY REALLY COMING OVER WITH
THEIR PARENTS?
OR ARE THEY BEING TRAFFICKED BY
CARTEL MEMBERS?
I HAVE INTRODUCED A BILL TO
REQUIRE D.N.A. TESTING AT THE
BORDER TO DETERMINE WHETHER OR
NOT TRAFFICKER OR THE PARENT,
WHOEVER THEY SAY THEY ARE IS
THAT REALLY THEM?
BUT WITH RESPECT TO THIS PRISON,
THIS IS JUST ONE OF MANY THINGS
I THINK YOU WILL SEE IN THE
MONTHS TO COME IF WE DON’T GET
THIS UNDER CONTROL AND IT
DOESN’T SEEM TO BE TRENDING THAT
WAY, WHICH IS WHY OUR GOVERNOR
AND STATE LEGISLATURE HAVE SAID
HERE IN TEXAS THAT WE HAVE GOT
TO DO SOMETHING OURSELVES.
WILL: CONGRESSMAN, I WANT TO ASK
YOU ABOUT BIG TECH.
BIG TECH SEEMS TO BE A TOPIC
THAT AT LEAST SOME OUT THERE
THINK MIGHT BE A PLACE WHERE
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS CAN
WORK TOGETHER.
THIS IS BECAUSE PRESIDENT JOE
BIDEN HAS PICKED AS HEAD OF THE
FTC LENA COHEN, SHE HAS NOW BEEN
APPROVED BY THE SENATE.
BIG TECH.
THAT BRINGS UP THE QUESTION CAN
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS WORK
ON THIS TOGETHER?
I’M A BIT SKEPTICAL BECAUSE IT
SEEMS LIKE WE ARE COMING AT IT
DIFFERENT ANGLES, REPUBLICANS
WORRIED ABOUT CENSORSHIP AND
DEMOCRATS UNDER THE GUISE OF
DISINFORMATION LOOKING FOR MORE
CENSORSHIP.
IS THERE COMMONALITY ANYWHERE?
>> I THINK THERE IS COMMONALITY.
RARELY WOULD YOU SEE PEOPLE
GETTING EXCITED ABOUT -- PEOPLE
ON THE CONSERVATIVE SIDE GETTING
EXCITED ABOUT A LIBERAL FTC
CHAIRWOMAN BUT LINDSEY GRAHAM
AND JOSHUA HOLLY ARE SOME OF THE
MANY SENATORS THAT CROSSED OVER
AND VOTED FOR HER CONFIRMATION.
I’M EXCITED TO SEE WHAT SHE HAS
GOING WITH TROPIC BREAKING UP
MONOPOLIES AND MAKE SURE THEY
DON’T GROW.
THESE BILLS ARE BIPARTISAN.
THE HEAD OF THE PROGRESSIVE
CONFERENCES IN JAYAPAL AND I ARE
WORKING ON A BILL TOGETHER.
I NEVER THOUGHT I WOULD WORK ON
A BILL WITH HER BUT WE ARE.
THE GOAL IS TO PREVENT THESE
GROWING MONOPOLIES FROM GETTING
LARGER YES, THERE ARE DIFFERENT
MOTIVATIONS ON THE DEMOCRAT SIDE
AND MY SIDE, BUT I THINK THE END
RESULT IS WE HAVE LARGE
COMPANIES THAT CONTROL LESS OF
OUR LIVES THEN WE WILL GET TO
THE POINT WHERE CENSORSHIP IS
NOT HAPPENING IN THE WAY THAT IT
IS.
NO ONE WOULD CARE IF FACEBOOK
MONITORED PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP
IF PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP HAD
ANOTHER AVENUE TO GO DOWN WITH
RESPECT TO SOCIAL MEDIA.
BUT BECAUSE FACEBOOK IS SO BIG.
IT’S REALLY IMPORTANT THAT THEY
HAVE BANNED HIM.
I ENVISION A DREAM SCENARIO
WHERE THERE IS ACTUAL
COMPETITION.
IF FACEBOOK BANS ME I DON’T CARE
BECAUSE I CAN GO SOMEWHERE ELSE.
THAT’S WHAT THESE BILLS SEEK TO
DO.
THEY SEEK TO INCREASE FREE
MARKET AND LESSEN THE RELIANCE
ON ONE OR TWO COMPANIES THAT ARE
SO BIG THAT THEY DOMINATE OUR
LIVES.
PETE: WILL BE GREAT TO SEE WE
WILL SEE IF ANYTHING LIKE THAT
IS TRULY POSSIBLE ON CAPITOL